I mean where you know what it is we're
just a really stupid we're done as human
beings were done I mean when we come out
the womb we're done we can't do [ __ ] for
like 12 13 years we literally can't do
anything antelope come out of the womb
like this come on [ __ ] there's lions we
we cut us we can't we don't even come
out we have to be pulled our back we're
pretty dumb and then now check this out
- in modern times right now you have to
go to school for 20 years
before you're considered smart a master
at something 20 years another five if
you want your PhD do you know the life
expectancy of the people that wrote the
Bible
it's like 30-ish how smart could they be
[Applause]
I'm just throwing it out no we just
think you know we need we have stories
to help us understand [ __ ] the Bible is
missing one sentence on the cover based
off true events hey when you when you
see a movie this is based on true events
what does that tell you well this is
probably [ __ ] I mean the ship sank
but there wasn't a dude in the front
going King in a world that's called
embellishment we embellished the
mythology so we can help ourselves
understand but it doesn't mean it
actually happen like that
see Bible people get mad at me because
they think Noah was standing in front of
a boat with a clipboard like this let's
get started
red ants welcome aboard
black ants
thank you snails the [ __ ] story you
know to me it's mythology oh no don't
get mad at me